holy smokes another crazy position out
of a night or
and of course at night when there is
alexi there is a night or
also what happened look at look at
jeffrey he is in the same place
oh yeah he is no somebody in the in the
chat said it says
versus head and what is this
opening because jeffrey has only spent
nine seconds
and alexi is now thinking and clearly
there's some discovery on this rook on
eight and the bar just
shot up in jeffrey's favor so there must
be a tactic that just
wins for white on the spot yeah i mean
they're going into this position without
full preparation okay so what about
we're on
night after night
d5 i would maybe just castle
i mean is that so outlet whoa if you
castle here that i mean that feels
well let me look but i i think that hmm
see if i was gonna say oh
but you have to sort of play position i
think the point is
black cannot develop if he puts his
bishop out to e7 you take it
if he places his knight on c6 you take
it and go knight f6 check
black is paralyzed the reality is white
is not in a hurry he can actually
tighten the screws
yeah i'm just showing some of these
positions here and just every tactic
should favor
white with that black king stuck in the
center and so like what else can you do
here so we're talking knight c6 doesn't
work because knight takes a knight f6
check
so what day seven rook a7 then there's a
discovery down on that rook
stop it but right now exactly maybe
knight takes b5 maybe you give up that
rook
just knight just trying to develop yeah
right i take on e6 i force you to take
with something i just take this rook and
yikes yeah that's bad oh actually maybe
you can even throw in a bit no bishop v6
is covered by the night i was like
trying to get
a little cute over there mm-hmm i i
failed so
i just look at another thing just i know
it's crazy
if you play bishop d3 robert knight
takes c6 fe queen g6 check becomes a
possibility
in some lines you're such a i had to i
had to indicate that's not that it's
important because i just want to should
take c6 exists but just have to point it
out i wanted to show something like this
like queen g6 give me that
checkmate taking away all the squares
from your king it's boxed in
that would be too good to be true he has
taken and gone a5 has serrano
trying to create chances but what he's
trying to do is desperately get a knight
to c5
i don't think he's gonna have to look at
this look at this
gosh at a6 can he hold on but then even
knight c7 check
yeah 97 looks good at the very least
because the point i've done is making
good is knight c7 you take i take the
queen takes
the end you win a piece for black but
don't forget about that rook that's
hanging in the corner and the queen
spying it so i know i drew a bunch of
arrows so i'll just
put them on the board for everybody
thank you for your rook and it's maybe
not the worst possible
situation for black there is an attack
on the bishop behind it is a check on c3
so
you do have to be careful here for white
and
that's why jeffrey hasn't moved yet i
would consider castling here actually
in these positions sometimes when you
analyze a lot with computers
what you see is that they uh somehow
prioritize the sort of direct
development but jeffrey has gone knight
c7 he's gone for the exchange
my worry is this position he's got to
find a good move maybe rook c1 yep
and it's protective that's very
important it is defended
because otherwise like bishop b5 or pawn
d5 would exploit the fact that the rook
is under attack behind the bishop but
as is usually the case a rook wins a
stare down with a queen
especially when a bishop is defending
the c1 square so black has
nada white can castle next the a5 pawn
is also
oh man buckle up bishop takes e6 anybody
yeah this is yeah this is not looking
good knight c3
seems to be forced but bishop takes d7
the group can even castle in the end and
just
give that rook yeah there is no good
news i was going to say the good news is
that castling's met with 92 check but
you're right even there
i would cast him yeah i'm with you
that is the extent of white's dominance
right you check you move the king away
wherever
knight takes rook takes and your king is
on d7 you haven't developed you can't
move your bishop because
rook will be hanging behind it yikes
yikes yikes yeah
yikes and my friend my good friend sam
shankland
uh grandmaster sam shane club also from
the bay area he advocates this a lot
uh where you know you make a move that
initially seems impossible
because of some sort of refutation such
as the move castles and he says you know
the next question that you always have
to ask yourself is what happens if i do
it anyway
you sort of hack your brain into
considering a move that your sort of
animal brain refutes because of a
superficial reason if that makes sense
right oh oh my gosh
whoa sick blue wheat is hitting me
oh my gosh and jeffrey just can't oh
that's a huge
huge move i mean white is still better
but that's a lion's share of his
advantage
we need to look at that again and the
move d5
blocked the queen from retreating but
more importantly allowed this
insane tactic of queen h2
check he's he's trying to keep the smile
off his face i can tell serrano's trying
to smile
look at him biting the ends of his lips
i mean i mean and he should smile
that is a sick idea wow and white is
still better
however you look at the material it is a
knight and a pawn for
a rook and the a2 pawn can actually be
captured but then you lose the g7 pawn
so i would say daniel that here is a
very tough decision for alexi
because giving up the g7 pawn is really
hard because getting
a clear pawn majority to your opponent
so you take on a2 looks good you free up
your b-pawn but you lose an important
defending pawn against the passengers
and does take on a2 i think they
have a right move but it just is hard to
play psychologically and
jeffrey is you know not to
downplay his sort of demeanor and his
maturity he is just impervious to these
things
he just you know literally puts his head
down and plows forward so
but this is some serious counter play
now e4b3 this could turn around in
black's favor robert yeah you're saying
plow four these pawns are doing just
that bishop c5 that only attacks f2
it says d4 and then once d4 happens the
bishop no longer attacks this knight
so i just i just pushed these pawns i
mean can you take the knight on c3 is
that so crazy because
i'm trying to bring these puns closer
together and then bring my king over but
clearly that's not
i know you don't have time because if
you take b takes it like rooks
because rook c1 you say oh i stop your
pawns but after d4
king g2 you throw in bishop a3 to force
the rook up to c2
and then you defend this pawn between
bishop b2 and then you have d3 and you
win the game so you encourage the rook
up to an approachable square yeah he
pulls this out and i'm not going to
speculate any further because
we're commentators and commentators are
known to produce certain effects
but this is i i this is unbelievable
actually this is an incredible resource
that he just uncorked there
i mean where's my book i like to write
these things down so i'm writing down
this queen edge to this queen to check
oh my
yeah i have my notebook here it's it's
handy so it's uh
we're both taking the pens i don't have
a pen though we need a bag
i mean i'm running down right now so i
have one in my i actually have a pen
in my pocket i don't even know why i
have one in my pocket but i just do
there we go i wrote it down so i'm ready
to continue commenting i'm showing this
in some of my lessons today
oh okay well i didn't know you'd be you
know first of the punch there i don't
have any lessons today so
i'm just writing it down for my own
recollection
so king g2 was played it's
two past pawns here and that is
very bad news for jack can you imagine
after the first two games where jeffrey
was much better with the black pieces in
fact
completely winning if he had played
queenie one check before g4
and then in this game where he was up in
exchange
and then his opponent's king was in the
center overlooks queen h2 check and
doesn't just spoil his advantage but if
he loses this game
oh my gosh that would be a huge blow now
to put things into context here and i
don't think he is losing
uh but it's going to be very close and
he also could win this i mean because
he's got the pawn majority if he
contains the pawns
i know it sounds crazy but sometimes
these positions
can be very hard to defend uh because
once the initiative fizzles out robert
the king blockades the pawns the rook is
a force to be reckoned with on the other
side of the board
let me very concretely if i play d4 yeah
okay you play king f3 and if i play c2
what are you gonna do about that because
my idea is like bishop a3 next i guess
you have
e2 king d2 so your king does run and
that's a draw
oh yeah but my whole point was no you're
absolutely right
you want to have d3 and thank you for
your rook putting out a vulnerable
square
and otherwise he's got to find it okay
so he has played
he has brought his king he's playing for
a win
now what did now okay rook d8
oh are those v8 oh
yeah these pawns are too quick right now
d4 and bishop a3
all my lands well king d4 there will be
rook d8 check where's your king ranger
king e4
yeah i think he just runs like i guess
what you do here
okay king d5 you can just run your king
e4 and f3 and
and where does the bishop ah the bishop
on d4 well
what's what's white's move f3 ah okay
absolutely so with your points after c2
king d2
you don't have the good bishop move
because the rook is actually in the
right place behind the pawn i got you
right but then king d4 rook d akin c4
uh but then rook back to c8 so you try
to tie yourself to the bishop that's
what he does
oh now c2 channel oh that is a nice move
look at that
springs that off the slingshot
yes okay eight maybe his force but then
the king comes into c4b3 this is
unbelievable
i think it's just just winning
that is yup he has nothing i mean this
is
and he doesn't even go seek you he
doesn't even rush yeah because you know
because there's nothing that white can
do
exactly he's paralyzed he resigns the
game what
when look at sarna did you see that he
took a breath he's like
how in the world did i